父母只能出十万块钱，
他如果说付了房子的首付，
他的年终奖，
付了房子的首付，
他的公积金，
他再借点钱，
那他是不是第一应该是先还他的债，
什么时候才轮着给你攒什么彩礼钱啦，
结婚钱了，
孩子的这个备用金了，
什么时候才轮到你吧，
你自己琢磨一下啊。
我是98年的，
28岁，
我的原生家庭一般给不了我很多的帮助，
我的手里的存款有70万，
跟我男朋友在一起有三年，
他是程序员，
工资在33000W，
他的家庭也是给不了他太多的帮助，
在去年的时候，
我发现他有银行一个欠款20万，
在我的前置要求下，
他到现在已经全部还完了。
发生这件事情的时候，
他把他的钱都放在我这里，
让我替他保管，
我想问一下龙飞姐姐，
您觉得这种适合当结婚对象吗？
你现在手上这70万，
其中有多少是他的存款，
有多少是你的存款，
都是我自己的，
那他说钱交给你保管，
他现在有多少钱了？
因为他从去年过年的时候发现他有欠款20万，
他自己的工资包括年终奖一直在还他的外债，
就是到现在已经还清了，
他多少岁，
他也是28岁，
跟我同年了，
也就是说他现在是没有存款的状态，
是不是对没有存款，
那他之所以欠20万，
你有了解过他为什么欠这20万吗？
因为他工资收入是很高的哟，
他是程序员，
他可能第一份工作收入都不会低于1万块钱的，
是的，
他是属于那种比较大男，
我觉得就是比较，
就是什么都要钱，
他跟我说是从家里，
比如说就是从大学的时候，
他可能就是借一点点微贷，
然后后期他也有找女朋友啊什么之类的，
包括他跟我在一起的时候，
他对我花的钱也挺多的，
就比如说我跟他刚认识几天，
给我买个苹果手机，
我给他就是随口说了什么东西，
就是给我花钱，
就花钱在我身上都这么花，
我觉得在他前女友的身上肯定也是这么花的，
包括他对于他的金钱，
我觉得一点概念都没有，
就比如说其他的爱好没有，
就是打游戏，
然后我会发现之前的钱也有充游戏，
导致他到之前就是一直在恶性循环嘛，
然后一直欠啊什么，
我觉得你可能要谨慎的再观察一阵吧，
不要那么着急走入婚姻，
因为你自己对自己的生活安排是很到位的，
你能有70万的存款，
你才28岁，
你非常优秀了，
你太会过日子了，
是不是啊，
对，
就是我，
可能就是我自己的家庭，
我也知道，
我就自己也就是一直在赚钱，
不爱买一些什么奢侈品，
一直也会有存钱的这个习惯，
包括我的工作，
我也挺努力的，
我是之前是开一个美甲店，
前一个月的时候，
我觉得自己的一个提升不到，
然后就。
把那家店给了别人，
也是卖了点钱在手里，
对我自己的一个打算就是，
嗯，
觉得自己的知识应该还是不够，
就是想着努力也提升一下自己，
所以我觉得还是要谨慎观察一段时间，
你再谨慎观察个半年，
你看看他，
其实坦率的说候人是这样子的啊，
首先我们是自己的第一责任人，
对不对？
你看他的父母又帮不上他，
然后他自己28岁了，
他就没有真正的为自己去打算过，
你正常来说的话，
他父母帮不上忙，
他是不是还得想想我怎么赡养父母是吧，
我这一个月3万多块钱，
我到底应该怎么安排，
包括我以后我可能要成家，
我是不是应该安排一下，
我自己有多少存款，
对不对，
你28岁了，
不是18岁啊，
他马上就30岁的人了，
他首先得对自己的人生负责任，
他才有可能将来对孩子负责任，
对家庭负责任，
我跟我妈妈都觉得他这个人他欠多外债，
我没敢跟我妈说，
我就说他这是家庭的情况，
然后他的收入，
我妈就说你以后结婚什么，
比如说有孩子你之后怎么办，
就是想到这些我也不知道怎么办，
我觉得谨慎的在观察个半年，
不要着急步入婚姻，
有句老话说的特别好，
吃不穷穿不穷，
就是没有计划一辈子穷，
因为我们都是在一线城市，
在上海生活嘛，
然后最近就是。
房价比较跌嘛，
呃，
因为也谈了三年，
见了父母，
那他们家也就是说啊，
可以把就是定下来了嘛，
我就觉得没有打算生孩子的时候，
我觉得结婚对于我来说是没有意义的嘛，
然后我就觉得可以把这件事情先放在后面去做，
因为他不是过年也会发一个五份年终奖，
他会就是想着就是说在上海把首付钱给付了，
然后背着贷款嘛，
他年终奖得发多少钱呀，
嗯，
大概有个10W左右，
10W够付首付款了吗？
再加上他自己有公积金嘛，
公积金大概也有10W，
然后再加上他家里也会给个10W，
你看这30万对家里对他最大的帮助也就是10W 30万能付首付款了，
差不多就是再加上朋友什么的再帮助一下，
就是首付款是能付得起的，
首付款要多少钱啊，
差不多4~50这样子，
那付了首付款之后呢，
他还贷款一个月还多少呢？
因为他有公积金，
公积金的话他是差不多有交9000，
那装修呢，
装修的钱从哪里来呢？
他说他在赚了一年，
就这样子，
你清醒一点吧，
姐妹啊，
清醒一点再观察啊，
别那么着急啊，
好，
关于提升自己，
龙飞姐姐有什么好的方法跟建议吗？
某种了一个，
因为我这人比较功利，
就哪个挣钱我就干哪个。
原来我。
比如律师挣钱我就干律师，
后来发现自媒体挣钱我就干自媒体，
后来发现带货挣钱我就干带货，
我可能就是穷怕了，
哪个挣钱就干那个，
你琢磨一下，
你周围的这些七大姑八大姨，
同学姐姐、
表姐什么的，
谁干什么挣着钱了我就干哪个，
他的话你就建议我再关我，
我觉得你要谨慎观察一下，
因为他这日子的话，
你能算明白账的啊，
如果他年终奖10万块钱，
他去付首付，
他爸给10万块钱付首付，
他的公积金去付首付，
我问你他吃什么喝什么，
穿什么，
用什么，
那咱就是普普通通老百姓，
装修是不是也得二三十万，
你再怎么装修也得二三十万，
这钱从哪里来？
什么时候轮到你，
什么时候轮到孩子啊，
你琢磨一下啊，
好，
你这70万他要是知道的话，
就得打你70万的主意了，
因为他是知道我手里有20左右，
因为我前一段时间把店给卖掉了，
然后卖了20左右，
不管正他也就说这是你的钱，
也我没有告诉他我有70，
你想吧，
他父母只能出10万块钱，
他如果说付了房子的首付，
他的年终奖，
付了房子的首付，
他的公积金，
他再借点钱，
那他是不是第一应该是先还他的债，
什么时候才轮着给你攒什么彩礼钱啦，
结婚钱啦，
孩子的这个备用金了，
什么时候才轮到你吧，
你自己琢磨一下啊，
清醒一点，
好好算账，
好的好的好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
谢谢两位姐姐的拜，
我感觉第一。
应该是对自己负责任，
男孩子还是要自己有点存款啊，
对自己负责，
将来才有可能对别人负责，
你像干到28岁了，
欠20万，
你是怎么想的啊？
关键他收入这么高，
他不是说收入五千六千的，
他收入是几万几万的收入啊，
我感觉这事儿真的要认真观察他啊，
记得点赞关注哦。